we're coming back to first principles
all right and actually this is really
good because you guys are three
innocents can do this next part and to
your students well you will see while
this why they struggle in a second first
principles okay says for a to function
right it's derivative is given by how
does first principle start limit as H
approaches zero off good you've got rise
on the top or low bar H okay good so
let's just take that and do it for sine
so the derivative of sine X is equal to
limit H approaches zero or and right
away you can see the problem right at
least you can see the problem for tunes
things what's the problem they need you
got it we're gonna have to do something
with this guy right and three expansions
that's that's all you guys know right so
we're gonna we're going to expand that
in a second so we can work with it
that's all over H ok ok so remember what
our goal is is to somehow avoid having
an H on the denominator or if there is
an H on the done on it to be able to do
with it in some way
okay so let's expand and see where it
goes
okay you have your doubts I'm okay how
in this exam all the time this this year
is the exam that's all about introducing
that in your calculus and first ones
that kind of thing
after these exams we start ditching
first principles because you learn all
the rules that no longer require them so
so the reason why we do it now is
because you know this result before you
start using it you want to actually
prove it and that's why we come back to
first principles all right now by the
way just this side note you probably
don't think there's anything wrong with
this line but it's a bit weird because
there's actually two things in here
which are actually the names of
functions there they're kausch and shine
don't ask me why then that's just as is
why people would pronounce it that way
they called hyperbolic cos on a
hyperbolic sign it's yeah anyway so for
us it's just sign of the constant okay
fine I'm just not the expansion they
ever build it okay now what do we do
here what can we do um in previous times
what we've done is to deal with this a
little better we've had a couple of
tricks up our sleeves right sometimes we
added and subtracted something on the
numerator to make you know factorize it
easier sometimes we broke it apart into
two different limits okay and that's
what I'm going to suggest we're going to
do here now I admit it's not going to
look that intuitive but just follow with
me next slide let's go with this limit
and he's only going for down make sure I
write it correctly I'm going to
factorize first
long holiday
okay now at this point why if I
factorize this causes age minus one is
going to be really useful for us in a
second okay but before I can use it I
need to split apart these two parts of
the fraction into two different limits
okay so I want to put the first one yeah
which is sine X all that H and I've got
another 30 okay now do you remember just
as a side note okay that when we were
evaluating limits sometimes we could
take things out of the limit if they had
nothing to do with a ballerina lips
example okay when I said take the limit
as X approaches 2 of 5x okay because
this is number 5 right
it doesn't change no matter what value X
takes right so I can write this as 5
times the limit as X approaches 2 of X
okay so not only can I think of it as oh
it's going towards 10 I can think of
it's 5 times bigger than going towards 2
which is the same thing okay
and when you look at this line I can do
much the same but it's not as obvious
because all the letters right what can
you take out from both limits you can
take out different things okay from this
limit you've got this sign X which has
nothing to do with the H and over here
you can take out cos x which has also
nothing to do with the X okay so let's
take those out and then see what
okay now again I want to pause for a
minute you've got two limits here and
they both have their own tricks
associated with them okay so let's have
a thing about this guy okay
the limit as H approaches zero of all
this cause business okay now what does
cause look like cause looks like this
I'm going to drop both sides actually
okay so what happens to cause on H as H
approaches zero and you can think about
it from above the low rule it is the
last lesson right what does cause H
approach one correct because as I'm
getting toward zero the value up here is
just one okay so I'm just going to write
down on the side here because it's
helpful to me the limit as H approaches
0 of cos H right that limit is just
equal to 1 okay now by similar logic
okay let's think about this one over
here now this parts tricky up this
result actually relates to these earlier
steps so if you're not satisfied with
this I'm going to prove more rigorously
later but let's think about these graphs
okay sine of something okay and hmm if I
think of sine of X and X has two
different functions okay there's no sign
looks like an X it's just a straight
line passes through the origin
okay now you can go and verify this
number one by looking at a computer
graph it and zoom in okay or just take
some measurements what's happening is
you're approaching the origin as you
look at this one a look at this one
they're both approaching the same point
but not only are they approaching the
same point if i zoom in right everything
is getting really really close together
like these gradients are approaching the
same thing as well okay so therefore
sine H over H even though I can't just
put in H equals 0 on this limit it's a
really important one so important that's
why I'm going to prove it later this is
equal to 1 as well okay so I'm gonna
take both of these limits both of these
facts
I'm going to bring them in okay let me
go back to my own what's happening here
closet age is going towards one right so
what's cause of H minus one going
towards that's one minus one so this
this whole thing becomes zero right
so that's what the limit is you know
this guy this pull guard the front is
like I thought I was significant well
actually it gets multiplied by zero so
he just vanished off okay now what
happens to this side okay this limit as
we saw from the graphs it approaches one
so cos x times that limit which is one
is just project the derivative of sine
is causing okay so what do we requite
number one this whole first principle
set up number two there's three
expansion okay which allows us to
factorize break up the limits and so on
and number three the key piece just
looking at we haven't owned this limit
key on that's the important one okay and
i might think you might think okay it's
not that looks about right okay but this
you know this looks about right is the
same intuitive sort of approach which
gives us the right result but isn't
enough to say I've proved it okay so